all right yo bootleg podcast
rose crayons vic is here kevin what's
the deal welcome man
um for people who don't know who you are
what you do uh
you are a fixture in the la hip-hop
scene
um rosecrans ave is
the platform that you i i think uh a few
years ago
um is when i first kind of started
checking out what you were doing
um kind of give everyone a background
like what it is you do
and and um like keep kind of your
background in the la hip-hop scene
yeah so basically i started a blog like
maybe like six
going on seven years ago um called
rosecrans ave
and basically my whole thing was just i
wanted to document like the underground
la artists that
weren't getting played on radio or
weren't getting any attention
by like complex or anything like that
right so i was like you know what
i don't give a [ __ ] about the big
artists you know they're gonna get
picked up by all these other blogs
i'm gonna just focus on finding like the
new talent and growing with them
you know what i mean so that's what i
try to do i just taught myself how to
write
you know just really nobody like gave a
[ __ ] for like three years which was cool
because i got to like [ __ ] up
and like not have a large audience in
front of me you know what i mean so like
that was actually kind of cool when i
look back because you i [ __ ] up so
much yeah you know you kind of get to
like learn on the go and not a lot of
people were looking
exactly so i did that and nobody really
started to give a [ __ ] until
we booked uh oh three greedo at a show
at the echo
and it was like a monday night and we
brought like the whole city out
and then everybody was like oh [ __ ] like
damn like everybody's paying attention
to greedo now he got picked up by like
the fader
right and all these different places
started paying attention to him
and then we did it again with shoreline
mafia the next month and then
you know we had our podcasts on dash
radio rose crans radio
and then people just started to really
pay attention to like what we were doing
right
just started giving a [ __ ] in general
and so who like
who were kind of like the core artists
for you guys like as far as who you were
kind of getting behind early on
definitely draco
draco the ruler greedo shoreline
um who else there was like the easy colt
it was just like this you know really
even blue face you know
we were on blue face early we just got
behind every la artist early
um even like roddy rich like i wrote
about him in like 2017
right you know what i mean kalyn all
these people i just kind of watched them
grow
and i thought they were dope i didn't
know they would grow up to be like
megastars you know necessarily like like
rottie or anything like that of course
you know i just saw them grow and i
thought they were talented and i like
the music
you know i mean obviously what i've
noticed about the new generation at la
for the most part you know because
obviously sometimes
politics gets involved and people really
can't work with each other but like
for the most part it seems like there's
a whole wave of um
la artists the last couple of years that
have worked with each other embraced
each other
kind of had some camaraderie yeah and
that was kind of always the hang-up
about l.a
you know because people would always be
like atlanta everyone's together you
know like
yeah but i feel like there's been a
movement where everyone is
you know for the most part moving in the
same direction
you know obviously there's like i said
there's there's there's some beef
there's
dumb [ __ ] but is that something that you
noticed as well and like if like why do
you think that is
uh that was like really a goal of mine
to create really create a community
so that other artists can be aware of
other artists but i think it's like
three things i think it's
the fact that not too many of the pop
and rappers are gang banging
you know i mean like a few of them are
but not too many of them are
um two i feel like we had a lot to do
with it as far as
booking shows we book everybody on the
lineup everybody comes and meets each
other
okay that guy's cool okay i'll see
what's up you know what i mean it's just
like a
community gets built after a while and
then
um the other is just like um the fact
that everybody's winning everybody's
eating
like you can't really be that mad when
you have money in your pocket
you know what i mean like it's like yeah
this dude is like
selling hella albums or whatever he's
he's like 90 of everyone signed a tk
yeah that has something to do with the
two yeah
but it's like you know if everybody's
really winning and
it's not a bunch of like hungry people
like there's not much to fight about
you know what i'm saying so i feel like
it's like those three factors
yeah i think too like what i thought was
really
important and dope was when greedo and
rj did the show
and nothing happened oh that was
incredible i i
like the fact that that was insane and i
was like i'm not going to that show
yeah i remember me and edward's head was
like i'm not going to that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] and then the next day was
like
yo that [ __ ] was a beautiful situation
that was like the first versus damn near
low key
if you think about it and the fact that
like nothing happened like it almost
kind of like to me kind of showed
everybody like hey look you
because you know with la that the
certain [ __ ] is just
it seems as if it's impossible to change
yeah right and something like that to me
showed everybody like hey look like
there's another way to go about this all
of the homies were there
nothing happened it's you know at the
end of the day it's just like they're
getting money so what
again what is there like there's not too
much to be mad about you know
who do you consider uh out of the last
five years in la hip hop to be like
the the guy like the goat
uh i mean it's like i would think draco
you know but i also like on a major
major scale i would say roddy
yeah i'm gonna let's just take right
here okay let's take it out because he's
two
yeah okay so i'll say draco draco
because he went to jail for three years
got his spot back and elevated if
anything like oh yeah he's going crazy
you know what i'm saying like that's
what i was just talking to him about
like last week i'm like bro like
you were gone for three years but really
more almost like five
because before he came out for like
two months he was locked up for like
another like a year and a half like
before then so like for the majority of
the past five years he's been locked up
and his career is just still booming you
know he got out and just got to it
i think he had like i felt like he
recorded an album like it was already
done like a week
it was like talked to him i was like bro
you you got out of jail and went
straight to the booth
straight to literally straight to it and
so you know but
everybody you know gives him that that
respect though
you know what i mean like everybody's
like yeah like [ __ ] he's doing it what
can we say you know he's really like him
and then if he co-signs an artist like
that artist starts to blow and stuff
like that so with the latin [ __ ] that's
going on i saw you were just um
a part of that photo always a lot of the
la like mexican guys who are in town cng
and all those guys but
um you know there's a whole nother
movement going on there that's
[ __ ] amazing out of la yeah um just
in general
um but what what like like what do you
think
when it comes to like because i always
said like when i was growing up like
when i thought i'm from phoenix so mc
magic was like god right oh yeah
and i was like you know working at car
shows and [ __ ] but like the mexican rap
that was really popular was the chicano
rap
yeah and to me i mean little rockwell
classics yeah mcmaster got classics but
i always felt like
there was a um it did you had to be
it was almost like made specifically for
for for
for the people who got that yeah it
wasn't very inclusive to
random i feel like like a lot of the new
latin mcs that are doing their thing
like they make dope [ __ ] and they happen
to be mexican
that's really the key you know what i
mean because a lot of
like me growing up like i had like a
period of time where i did like the
chicano rap stuff i was into mc magics
and
and all that but then i just kind of
grew out of it because i wasn't like a
gangbanger
right i didn't relate too much the
things i like the music you know
but like it's almost like it's in such
like a
cult-like fan base that you couldn't
really get out of that box and they
could have a million views like [ __ ]
high power records high power records
all that [ __ ] them [ __ ] i better go to
the they'd have their boots at the
[ __ ] car shows their shits would be
booming
and then they have random albums like
busy bone and [ __ ] yeah they were they
were doing it on the independent tip
you could buy them at like warehouse you
selling [ __ ] like but yeah
i think that like that's something that
like it's like now there's artists where
it's like yo you could be a fan of this
guy and be
you know whoever you don't have to be a
mexican to like you know like the music
is just good you know
that's yeah that's the whole goal and
that's what i see everybody doing like
we had like that meeting yesterday and
it was dope
because yeah like they're just dope
artists who happen to be mexican that
some of them probably don't even speak
spanish like they don't incorporate
spanish into their lyrics or anything
like that it's just like
they grew up in la they're mexican they
have you know homies that are black
white chinese everything you know and
they just they rap like you know and
they're good what was give us the inside
of the meeting yesterday because i saw a
few people post it
yeah it was it was pretty dope um
basically we pulled up to uh abner mars
you know i'm normal fighter yeah he has
a spot in like belle gardens
a restaurant and so uh we all just
pulled up and
um basically like they're just planning
i mean like
the cool thing is that everybody knows
each other but it was like still like a
mixer because
you're still meeting people face to face
and feeling people's energy and stuff
like that
but like they're planning on doing like
a cipher
fire you know what i mean like something
like that to where everybody gets on a
song
and then possibly you know go on like a
tour all la artists
yeah all that alright well there's some
like little weirdos from like san diego
and then there's
um great name by the way i know right
yeah and la is like a little weirdo
he's a great guy it's funny i'm like i
wish he could change his name maybe it
sounds like that sounds like he might
have had a capone record back in the day
like a little weirdo featured mister he
sounds right
by the way mr capone not mexican not
mexican at all i think he's from iran
he's irate yeah he's iranian by the way
doesn't take away from like
you know he's he's man but but i when i
found that i was like really
it blew everybody's mind when i was like
nah that's a joke like somebody's
trolling or something i was like no it's
really real and i met him and then like
super nice guy yeah yeah and then i'm
just kind of looking like yeah he's
probably yeah yeah
like he's indian so coming out
is there going to be like a compilation
project or is it just going to just like
a
almost like an open network where now we
all know each other now we can all work
together
that it's it's that i don't think
there's going to be like a whole album
possibly
i mean that was probably only like the
second meeting and the first one i
attended so
um i think the goal is just to like to
get on a tour and tour across
the nation you know what i mean like hey
what up man how to interrupt the bootleg
cab podcast to tell you
about our good friends at odd socks all
right yo
shout out to them for sponsoring the
podcast but also we're being
such a fire company and they just
introduced
their draws that's right
odd socks now got your boxer briefs on
deck
some tapatio joints and then of course
they got the best socks in the game
look at these stone cold socks look at
these two i mean look
i love froot loops but i love these
froot loop socks these are fire i'm
taking those for myself
uh they got all the licenses breaking
bad mac dre
odb wwe street fighter whatever you want
they got
including these draws i love these draws
i got some on right now
so listen tap in with odd socks go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg cab and you will
save 20
off at checkout so oddsoxofficial.com
keyword bootleg kev
save 20 at check out and thank me later
so you also have put out
um like rose crans ave music
right is that something that you're
actively
working on maybe a whole and i want to
do a new album
i really do um but it's just like
takes up so much time like he's also
dealing with
dylan i mean look i put out i put out a
mixtape in 2013
yeah 21 songs it was all original it was
a [ __ ] pain in there oh my
god it was a lot because you like you're
not the artist so like you have to clear
every single and you just i think i
think singles is the way to go man yeah
because then you all cool we got one
done all right let's drop it you try to
put down a whole project
man yeah i have a i have a um
distribution label with me and callie so
we we put our singles like we just put
out one with like young t.o and
big swift and jakarta slim so that one's
pretty dope we put it out like
a month ago so that's cool like that but
i do want to work on the album
but i know i'm gonna have to like book
out like
black out like two months of my schedule
or something to like i'ma just get this
[ __ ] done
ignore damn near everything else who's
somebody in la right now that we don't
know that we're
that you think has got all the tools to
be the next star out of l.a
ramble ramble you heard the rumble i
have not so
he got a draco co-sign he almost sounds
a little like draco
but i feel like everyone sounds a little
yeah at this point but he
he's 20 years old and like he has
probably like four songs out
but you can tell how smart he is how
like his word play and everything is
like
just next level he did a song called
like a
ted talk and then the video is like him
doing like a ted talk and then he's like
thank you all for listening like it's
just he's on like a next level like
creativity especially for being that
young
and he's like you know street dude so he
has that element to him
um and yeah like labels are already like
on his head yeah so i honestly if i were
like to put my money on anybody it'd be
him yeah
yeah and i have no affiliation i've
never spoken to him or anything i just
don't even know him
no is it like like have you noticed like
because you built yourself into a
position where a lot of people look to
you
in the la scene like is it like a gift
and a curse
yeah sometimes because you know people
will be mad if like i don't [ __ ] with
them or something
you know what i mean like isn't that
crazy like you can tell someone like hey
man do your thing i'm not a fan of the
music
but like and they'll like hate like
they'll take that personal like will you
want me to just like
yeah or like if i don't want to pull up
to like studio sessions or like it's
just like
i just don't want to listen to shitty
music for like two hours like what do
you want me to do
someone just asked me about you
i think it was my boy ace about beans
oh yeah yeah okay he's like hey you know
this rose crayons dude
he's like rose crane's fake he's like i
think so he's like yo is it worth having
i was like yeah man he's [ __ ] lit in
l.a man you should i was like yeah
of course beans is crazy she's fine give
me your um cause i think obviously
the most obvious next superstar to la is
blast
you know what i'm saying yeah aside from
that that's like obvious yeah but like
that's like the no-brainer yeah yeah
he's out of here you know um
like you know head had put me on a blast
a long time ago because head tried to
sign blast
and uh yeah the dude's out of here yeah
you know what i'm saying like
like were you like hip to blast like
before he was before he put out the like
the tape with bino
or was that something cause like man hit
you know he does it all
yeah i wasn't as hip to him as i as i
would like to be like right
i had heard the name i definitely had i
had heard a song called um
i think like fallen and this was like
and then there's another one called body
and i was just like damn these are dope
but i just listened to the singles i
didn't really like
go the extra mile and like look them up
on youtube or all you know all that
um but then going back like after he put
out the song with bino
um and the tape and everything then i
like was like oh i
had heard of him before because he was
in a group
called king and blast and it was like a
duo right
right but like to me like and there and
they presented themselves as like i.e
artists
and then that king dude like no shade
like he just wasn't very good right
right
so like i think that was like it
probably came across my radar
but it wasn't memorable because i heard
like the black dude and was just like
yeah i'm good
and you know it's just stuff like that
happens because there's like a song from
probably like two years ago that i went
back and looked up and i was like dude
this song is
last part on this song is incredible and
then the other thing and it has like 2
000 views to this day probably
so it's just and it's it's something
like that but
i wish i would have been more hip on him
but he wasn't putting out solo music for
that long before he like blew up really
not for sure um you you got the show on
no jumper
mad lately about to do 30 episodes or
just
we just hit 30. we just hit 30. yeah um
so congrats on that i appreciate that
once a week
yeah every monday so every monday it's
you gabe c i forget the young lady's
name
gina gina views um how did that come
come to be
um so adam i know i've been knowing adam
for like three years
now um no probably four yeah four since
like 2017
like around the time we're like
shoreline right was blowing up greedo
all them
we just kept running into each other and
um
i had them on my podcast once and then
after that
i would just like send them emails of
like dope videos that i thought were
dope and then people like cool i'm gonna
put this on the no jumper youtube and
i just kept like a constant line of
communication with him for a while and
um you know like we'd run into each
other certain places i'd
i think he started to grow like more of
a respect for me because a lot of places
he would be i would be
you know what i'm saying like i was
enrolling out of miami he was enrolling
on miami i was enrolling out in new york
he was there
any concert backstage did he see me i
was just hustling you know what i mean
so like
um we just grew like a cool relationship
and then at the beginning of 2020
he like said he wanted to meet went to
his office and then he was like yeah i
want you to do like a podcast or
something
he's like not rose crane's radio though
i want you to do something different and
i was like all right cool
and then like covet happened and then so
like everything just kind of pushed back
and all that stuff and then he hit me
again in like
august i want to say august or september
and was like hey
you know did you want to do that podcast
still like we're about to you know
have some more podcasts on here and i
was like [ __ ] yeah
and i said give me like three four days
to come up with like a concept
and a name and everything and so came up
with the name
recruited my co-host you know i had gina
i had gabe
and then we did like a photo shoot and i
shot everything to him in like three
four days he was like oh [ __ ]
like it was like ready to go yeah he's
like dave you guys are ready to go i'm
like yeah we're [ __ ] ready to go
what's um
because you were doing the rosecrans
radio what is like the like something
that you learned
doing because it's kind of a different
type of thing so like yeah
you know with any with anything you get
better as time goes but what's something
you had to kind of like
learn from making the switch and doing
mad lately
um it's streamed on youtube so people
comment yeah
i mean yeah it's just a way different
platform so i approach it differently
like
rosecrans radio was just like me
interviewing artists or
talking you know not too deeply i wasn't
really
trying to like make people laugh
anything too much like it was just kind
of like a
i wanted to had like a more serious tone
on there i guess you could say
but then i'm like okay we're going no
jumper like they have a certain audience
yeah you guys are definitely shooting
the [ __ ] now you know what i'm saying so
i'm like
we have to turn it up to a certain
extent or people are going to call us
boring or whatever and
the funny thing is that like the way i
am on mad lately like
that's really the real that's you yeah
you know what i'm saying when i'm out
with my homies and stuff like that so
i'm like [ __ ] it i'm gonna just put
myself on display and like
it like ruins my life but it like makes
it way better at the same time because
i'm a little too honest sometimes
and it's dope you know shout out to gabe
who's somebody who's a very underrated
figure in
oh yeah definitely i always say he's
kind of like power 106 is like sauce
yeah like a lot of that [ __ ] that gets
played late at night hell yeah
now all them dudes on [ __ ] not for i'd
be tricking gabe into liking some [ __ ]
we were trying to steal him in real
ninety two three for a while i heard
about that he was definitely trying to
yeah but yeah shout out to him um what's
next for
obviously you want to put out more music
but what is next for your platform for
you
um just doing more shows um we have
don't come to l.a we we filmed
that and um to give a little backstory
and you did like a south by
thing called don't come to l.a.t yeah so
that's so we did a concert series
um back in 2018 where we booked
everybody like
that's popping in l.a besides draco and
greedo because they were locked up
but we had like blue face rushy hazy
chike
one take jay everybody like hella early
so we had all them we create we really
created that community jay parikh all
them
and we only did five shows but every
single one of those shows was like
incredible we had like skrillex pull up
don kennedy j305 like
the crowd was even more star-studded
sometimes than like the performers
hey texas dude back on my phone
oh nice there it is yeah freddy gibbs
pulled up to perform
wow you know what i'm saying like who
did fred pull up to perform with uh 211.
oh that makes sense yeah yeah yeah so
um omb peasy like we just had like a
crazy amount of like special guests
always and it was such a dope vibe so
we made sure to like never dilute that
brand right and
we only did we only did it when we knew
we could be dope right so we did five
and then we did another one at south by
that's when we brought out reason we
brought out
um ruchi kalyn we just nardwar pulled up
like so crazy it was incredible andrew
barber was there like
it was an incredible show and we've been
for the last two years we've been trying
to put it together to do it again but
like
conflicting schedules cyprus was on tour
for like two years straight with
shoreline um
jeff and i were busy so uh this past
weekend we just recorded
like uh we're gonna do like a live like
a stream type thing yeah but
also we're gonna make it more like of a
documentary like i guess you could say
like a um
almost like a fate to black i mean
that's like obviously the best case
studies of course of course
but something like that you know what i
mean we documented the whole day
document the old shows put interviews in
there
you know what i mean all that stuff so
like really make it like a timeless
piece that people can watch
20 years from now and be like oh okay
this was this era in la
you know so like we filmed the
performance aspects of it
probably in about two weeks we're gonna
perform like we're gonna do the
interviews
right and just you know have the editors
put all the sauce on it and then
hopefully release it like in june
last thing where do you see la going
music wise in the next five years
like like hot like cause i always say
like
there's been so many artists who i
thought should have been bigger
yeah to come out of la over the last 10
years or so like someone like joe moses
you know i mean like there's like guys
who like man like rj's a perfect example
yeah
but i don't know what the disconnect was
that didn't
escalate as big outside of la as we had
hoped
um and i think that's with some of the
the newer generation there's some
potential there you know what i'm saying
what do you
like where do you see things going man i
mean
if if we can get by the way rj and joe
moses aren't done yeah yeah not at all
but i think if if la continues to build
like a strong community
um and have a lot of like key people
behind the scenes
making these moves that will actually
cross brand to
with artists in atlanta with in and
artists in like new york and
right you know across the the globe then
i think we have the talent to really
like wrench it like
and i'm obviously super biased but like
you have blast you have
beeno you have caitlyn you have all
these artists that don't only make
westeros they make music records
no matter where they're at that's what
i'm saying we have roddy unicorns so
it's like
we have all different types of artists
we have draco um doing songs with osuna
and drake and stuff like that you know
what i mean so i honestly like in the
next five years like
everybody stays on their [ __ ] doesn't
get complacent
you know and happy with just making like
10 bands a show and stuff like that it's
like
i think we could really run [ __ ] there
it is rose crans vic bouley cat podcast
appreciate you bro perfect